[Music]
foreign
[Music]
whether the big screens will be lit with
monsters and Mayhem this year Well if
not then you have five seconds to think
about it before we start showcasing the
15 monster movies and shows that are
going to be seen in 2023 let's get to it
number one a new Godzilla from tohos
Godzilla Zero movie so the First on this
list is none other than the king of
monsters and this year we will be seeing
a new incarnation of him in a yet
Untitled film by none other than Touhou
itself to be released in November there
is no trailer as of yet but we will
surely see one in the coming months but
one thing is for sure a live action
version of G-Man is always a thrill
number two Autobots Decepticons
terracons and maximals and Transformers
rise of the Beast here in the sequel to
Bumblebee and a soft reboot of the
Beavers said to be released in June
there will be quite a number of
Transformers which will include the fan
favorites like Optimus Prime Bumblebee
and also new animal-based Transformers
in the case of maximals and deadly
zombie-like terracons
number three karathan and underwater
creatures as well as the hollow Earth
dinosaurs in Aquaman and the lost
kingdom said to be released in December
this movie Will Follow The Adventures of
Aquaman deep into the lost kingdom that
can only be accessed through portals
deep in the trench here in this place
there will be gigantic monsters like the
karatan and other monsters and even
dinosaurs
number four the Obelisk and Marvel
monsters and Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
3. I know that the MCU has taken quite a
downturn with recent movies but for
Monster fans we did see quite a few in
Shang Chi and Doctor Strange and now
with volume 3 of Guardians we will
definitely have a feast on space
monsters like the Obelisk and maybe even
celestials or other Delhi
interdimensional monsters release date
in May number 5 the sand worm in the
Dune sequel well the last movie left us
with a cliffhanger as to what will
happen to Paula trades and his faction
so here in the sequel set to be released
in November we will not only see more of
the story of Paul eventually on his way
to becoming the god emperor of the
Galaxy but also more of the shy halut
also known as the gigantic sand worms of
the planet arakis
number six the Tyrannosaurus Rex and
Cretaceous dinosaurs in a movie called
65. last year was a dinosaur mess with
the release of Jurassic world dominion
and a not so good storyline that was
kind of like repetitive here in 65
humans will travel back in time to 65
million years in the past and struggle
to survive against the gigantic reptiles
in their home turf and also temporal
Turf the Cretaceous Period to be
released in March
number 7 the monster verse Titans in
Godzilla and the Titans so if you think
that Godzilla zero is the only G-Man to
be seen in 2023 then you are completely
in the dark the most of us will finally
launch a live action series following
Godzilla and what happened after San
Francisco from the first movie with a
release date not yet announced the
series is now creating anxiety on when
will we actually see Godzilla the murals
Muto Prime and other Titans this year
number eight the Megalodon shark and
maybe even the Leviathan in the Met 2
the trench said to be released in August
during the times when we still like to
hit the beaches the beers and bars the
mech will follow humans as they uncover
the hidden ecosystem under the Mariana's
Trench and meet face to face again with
the gigantic shark the Megalodon which
might be a new specimen or even the
newborns seen at the end of the last
movie
number nine quite a few types of dragons
and fantasy creatures in the movie
Dungeons and Dragons this is an
adaptation of the Famous Board Game
which was also the inspiration for the
stranger things monsters we will follow
a few Heroes elves humans and whatnot as
they go on an adventure which will
include seeing a few types of dragons on
the way including one gigantic fat ass
dragon that has small wings but still
managing to look like Deathwing from
World of Warcraft amazing
number 10. a dragon and other creatures
and Shazam part 2. well titled the fury
of the Gods it will feature an enormous
wooden Dragon alongside other
mythological creatures like unicorns
magicals minotaurs and even Cyclops
fighting against the manifestation of
the Gods Powers which is Shazam and his
orphan siblings this movie is said to be
released in March and fresh from House
of the dragon Memories there will be
comparisons between dragons
number 11 the weird nanoscopic Quantum
verse creatures in Ant-Man and there was
quantumania another MCU movie that is
really being scanned because of the low
performances of the recent releases this
Ant-Man movie is said to be released in
February and will follow the
protagonists meeting up against gang the
Conqueror and also fighting strange
monsters from the quantum verse
number 12 new types of aliens and robots
in Rebel moon with the story set in a
peaceful Colony on the edge of the
Galaxy threatened by the armies of a
Tyran Gora a young woman who has a
mysterious boss to seek out Warriors
from nearby planets is said to help
challenge the region or the Tyrant this
movie will feature not just humans but
also aliens in weird designs and also
deadly robots and mechs number 13 yamata
no Orochi the eight-headed dragon in
Brush of the god this upcoming Special
Effects gaiju movie not made by Touhou
is one to watch for the film was
crowdfunded via motion Gallery in
September 2020 and will feature quite a
number of gigantic monsters including an
eight-headed dragon that looks very
similar to Ghidorah but has eight heads
instead of three and so its name is
Orochi yamata no oroji number 14 a
number of gigantic and small sized
kaijus in Kaiju number 8. the sorry
background is as follows in Japan
monsters known as Kaiju regularly
attacked the population and the Japanese
Defense Force it starts with killing
them and defending the country one such
Defender gets transformed into a Kaiju
killing monster dub as gaiju number 8
and fights these monsters on their own
terms this is an anime
and number 15 naked humanoid Titans in
the last season of Attack on Titan this
one is another anime and it is the final
season for monster and anime fans alike
that are addicted to watching naked
Titans fight tiny humans and each other
this Series has a release date of March
the 4th these Titans just keep getting
bigger unfortunately by the end of the
show we will have a final size list of
all of them and there will be
comparisons
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam
[Music]